à notre baromètre mensuel votre
baromètre d'Auxerre one pour les chaînes
parlementaire et la presse régionale on
va parler dans quelques instants de
l'image de la nuque et du RN mais
d'abord on va parler de la côte de
popularité et Alex on va voir que la
côte de popularité des responsables
politiques et du côté de l'exécutif les
chiffres ne sont pas bons chute de
popularité pour Emmanuel Macron le
président de la République 38% des
personnes interrogées dans ce baromètre
considèrent qu'il est un bon Président
c'est 6 points de moins que le mois
dernier je suis encore plus forte pour
la nouvelle Première ministre Elisabeth
borne elle recueille dans ce baromètre
33% d'opinion favorables à ces 10 points
de moins qu'au mois de mai et ce qui est
intéressant dans cette étude c'est qu'il
y a presque une baisse généralisée de la
popularité pour les responsables
politiques avec par exemple Edouard
Philippe l'homme politique le préféré
des Français qui perd trois points une
cote qui baisse également pour Jean-Luc
Mélenchon ainsi que pour les ministres
oliveiran et Olivier Véran et Gérald
Darmanin au final elle est seule qui
tirent leur épingle du jeu en termes de
popularité ce sont les dirigeants du RN
Marine Le Pen et Jordan regarder là plus
un point pour tous les deux il surf sur
le très bon score du rassemblement
national au législative cette baisse de
popularité de l'exécutif il y a deux
mouvements différents pour Emmanuel
Macron ce qu'on observe c'est que 38%
des Français jusque c'est un bon
Président c'est 6 points de moins que le
mois dernier surtout ce qui faut bien
avoir en tête c'est que la difficulté
pour Emmanuel Macron aujourd'hui c'est
de rassembler dans un contexte où son
capital de soutien se détériore si on
devait faire un parallèle avec les deux
derniers présidents réélus sous la 5ème
République François Mitterrand a mis 3
ans de 88 à 91 à passer dans son
deuxième mandat sous la barre des 40% de
bonnes opinions Jacques Chirac également
c'est en 2005 seulement au moment des
discussions sur le traité européen en
mai 2005 qu'il arrive sous la barre des
40% et Emmanuel Macron pour citer un
exemple plus récent lui a mis un an à
passer sous la barre des 40% lors de son
premier mandat c'était après les
théories Billis de l'affaire Benalla
donc c'est ça indique vraiment quoi
mais à moi et ça indique que non
seulement on voyait dans les baromètres
le mois dernier qui avait pas d'état de
grâce mais ce qu'on voit c'est que il y
a non seulement pas les draps mais en
plus une montée de la défiance ça c'est
le point important le deuxième point
important c'est qu'il baisse dans les
catégories qui le soutenaient plus
fortement dans l'opinion chez les 50 ans
et plus chez les cadres finalement il
paye peut-être en popularité aujourd'hui
une certaine instabilité alors que
c'était plutôt le président de
l'alignement des planètes jusque là
aujourd'hui peut-être que ces électeurs
qui lui étaient fidèles lui reproche
cette instabilité à l'Assemblée
nationale pour Elisabeth borne le
résultat est tout aussi préoccupant
parce qu'elle a la mission de de
rassembler le plus largement possible
mais elle n'est plus soutenue
majoritairement que par les
sympathisants de renaissance et des
républicains donc ça montre la
difficulté dans laquelle se situe la
première ministre en terme de
républicains ça c'est peut-être
important en vue de construire une
absolument
auprès des sympathisants PS et des
sympathisants Europe Écologie Les Verts
et pour encadrer aussi ce 33% de bonnes
opinions mon égard aujourd'hui Jean
Castex n'est jamais descendu sous 34% de
bonnes opinions sur la période 2020 2022
c'est dire le la perte de crédit pour la
première ministre après deux mois à
Matignon ça veut dire que quinquennat
démarre pas sous le meilleur hospices
pour eux-mêmes Macron Elisabeth bordel
non il démarre pas sur ce des meilleurs
auspices je pense qu'il y a aussi le
fait pour Emmanuel Macron qui en est à
ce deuxième quinquennat c'est que le
premier quinquennat n'est pas passé il a
géré les crises mais elle lui revienne
tout de même il ne les a pas digérés je
pense qu'il lui revienne un peu en
boomerang et que le second quinquennat
pardonnez-moi
il n'est pas arrivé à se projeter il n'a
pas fait campagne son projet et soit
inexistant soit limité à une réforme des
retraites quelque chose qui est loin
d'être aussi galvanisant et n'entraînant
pas dynamique particulière et puis pour
vous rejoindre troisième point dans la
crise dans laquelle on se trouve et qui
explique peut-être la déception de son
socle de fidèles ce qui était fidèle
c'est que tout ce qui l'incarnait on
était pour on était compte mais parmi
ces fidèles on était plutôt pour
c'est-à-dire la verticalité le côté
jupitérien pour employer ce mot-là de la
présidence bah là il l'a perdu quand
même en grande partie il a perdu la main
c'est plus qu'il fait c'est bon bon on
voit pas du tout le l'axe c'est le cap
qui le prend et puis très rapidement
l'Europe aussi qui voulait incarner qui
était un élément fort bon il va finir sa
présidence il l'Europe a réussi quelques
progrès mais bon il y a la guerre sur le
territoire européen ce qui est terrible
et dernier point Mounir viendra aussi le
troisième point qui était je pense un
des axes forts de son armature
idéologique qui était la lutte contre le
Front national contre le rassemblement
national on l'a vu encore la
présidentielle on en parlera peut-être
tout à l'heure avec les fritements du
Front républicain qu'on veuille ou non
avec des soubresauts de la part et de la
présidence et de la majorité bah
celui-là aussi ses frites et qu'est-ce
qui reste au bout du compte ben Emmanuel
Macron à nous dire ce qui comment il
peut transformer le plomb en or ouais
d'autant que c'est intéressant dans le
je vous étudiez à la côte des
personnalités politiques des principales
personnelles politiques m'ont et là on
voit que ça baisse j'ai tout le monde
même chez Édouard Philippe qui était le
plus populaire des hommes politiques
sauf pour Jordan Bardella et Marine Le
Pen oui tout à fait mais en fait
finalement ça ça concentre le la
réflexion autour de cette polarisation
c'est que les blocs sont de plus en plus
homogène à l'intérieur et hétérogène
sans passerelle avec les autres jeux il
y a pas de passerelle entre la nupes et
la majorité présidentielle ni entre la
majorité présidentielle le rassemblement
national finalement on a beaucoup de
personnalités qui ont des codes
d'adhésion autour de 30% sans que ça
aille le seul qui soit vraiment
transversal là dedans c'est Édouard
Philippe Jean Castex il était aussi le
mois dernier avec 40% de côtes
d'adhésion mais finalement c'est vrai
qu'on a des blocs très balconisés une
tripolarisation qu'on retrouve même dans
les questions d'opinion avec le
rassemblement national qui progresse et
qui est dans une dynamique très forte en
effet et justement on va parler du
rassemblement national plus longuement
Alex est-ce que la bonne cause de Marine
Le Pen se répercute sur l'image du
rassemblement national les chiffres sont
bons pour le parti rassemblement
national 40% des Français en ion une
image une opinion favorable et c'est un
chiffre qui s'inscrit dans une dynamique
depuis des années pour ce parti sa cote
de popularité en 2011 quand Marine Le
Pen a pris le parti et bien l'été à 12%
d'opinion favorables et au fil des
années elle n'a cessé de croître alors
quelles sont les qualificatifs positifs
dans l'esprit des Français vis-à-vis du
rassemblement national et bien plus de
la moitié estime que c'est un parti
unique 47% pense qu'il défend bien les
classes populaires 42% estiment qu'il
peut assurer de meilleures conditions de
vie mais il inspire quand même des
qualificatifs négatifs également en
revanche et avec 64% des Français qui le
jugent comme un parti d'extrême droite
57% pense qu'il peut amener désordre et
53% estiment que c'est un parti raciste
une dernière question à quoi ressemble
le sympathisant type du rassemblement
national quel est son portrait robot et
bien on peut dire qu'il vit en milieu
rural dans un foyer modeste qu'il a
entre 50 et 64 ans et un niveau de
diplôme inférieur au bac on le voit
alors il y a du bon et du mauvais
évidemment on va en parler Janick mais
est-ce que au vu de ce que pense
aujourd'hui les Français du
rassemblement national on peut dire que
Marine Le Pen a réussi la
dédiabolisation de son parti ou pas
alors pas totalement si c'est votre
question pas totalement je pense que le
je vais répondre à votre question mais
je pense que le rassemblement national
est en crise de croissance alors elle
est en croissance on l'a rappelé on le
voit avec la notoriété on l'a vu pendant
la présidentielle c'est la deuxième fois
qu'elle est au second tour elle s'encre
je parle de Marine Le Pen et de son
parti dans le paysage politique on a vu
collégislatives et bah l'été devenu
il n'avait même pas de groupe il y a
trois mois si je puis dire où il y a
deux mois elle est devenue la première
d'opposition droite et gauche confondues
et on le disait tout à l'heure c'est
aussi grâce en partie au front
républicain qui s'effrite aussi bien de
Jean-Luc Mélenchon on l'a déjà vu en
2017 au LR et même à une partie de la
macronie mais elle est en crise aussi et
là je réponds directement à votre
question et le sondage nous le montrait
ça ça la force j'allais dire stratégique
et intellectuelle et doctrinal de Marine
Le Pen depuis notamment 10 ans qu'elle a
pris les commandes de du parti c'est
effectivement de des diaboliser de faire
oublier l'image racique xénophobe voir
antisémite de son parti que portait
encore son père lorsqu'il est à la tête
du Front national elle n'a eu de cesse
d'effacer de revenir sur cette image là
sauf que
en partie en partie réussie mais elle a
aussi en partie échoué on le voit à
travers les chiffres que vous montrez
c'est quand même extrêmement important
que je crois c'est plus de 60% des
Français qui estiment qu'elle est encore
raciste ou qu'elle était extraite
extrême
et on le voit
aujourd'hui entre guillemets à la faveur
du débat sur l'IVG du coup les
projecteurs sont portés sur
quelques-unes des incarnations des
députés on voit qu'il y a quand même
quelques députés encore rassemblement
national qui viennent d'entrée à
l'assemblée qui ont dépassé pour le mois
sulfureux donc cette désabolisation
n'est pas encore terminée jusqu'à quand
va pouvoir va-t-elle pouvoir l'amener ça
c'est entre les mains de Marine Le Pen
mais en revanche et je pense c'est le la
deuxième faiblesse la stratégie de de
diabolisation et d'institutionnalisation
parce qu'il s'agit bien de ça maintenant
pour Madame Le Pen et sont partis c'est
que son avenir n'est pas totalement
entre les mains l'avenir du du
rassemblement national je veux dire par
là que le regard des français mais aussi
la stratégie des autres ressenti
notamment de droite par rapport aux
Front national maintenant à l'étage
auquel elle est arrivée qui est une
sorte de plafond de verre qui a bien sûr
augmenté augmentée mais il faut
maintenant que les autres parties
notamment les LR encore une fois se
détermine par rapport à la stratégie qui
vont pouvoir qui vont accepter de mener
vis-à-vis du Front national permet
habilité plus grande ou pas justement
pour revenir sur ce que disent sur cette
image là on a un peu l'impression dans
votre enquête que Marine Le Pen elle
apparaît comme une réponse au problème
d'une partie des Français notamment les
classes populaires mais qu'elles gomme
pas l'image du Front national pour les
Français on a l'impression que le
rassemblement national ça reste la
continuité du Front national est-ce que
c'est dans une certaine mesure et puis
surtout pour rebondir sur ce que disait
janikalini quand on regarde plus en
détail la cote d'adhésion de Marine Le
Pen auprès des sympathisants de la
droite elle est quand même très clivée à
droite elle est de 95% auprès des
sympathisants de l'extrême droite par
contre elle n'est que de 31% auprès des
sympathisant de la droite modérée donc
des républicains et de lui donc il y a
quand même un vrai une vraie digue à
l'intérieur de la droite ça c'est le
premier point le deuxième point sur le
la progression du rassemblement national
ce qui est très intéressant ce que vous
disiez multiplié par 4 sa popularité en
disant on voit bien que la stratégie
quand même de normalisation du parti et
quand même en bout de en bout de piste
que 56% des Français nous disaient à 2
ans le rassemblement national doit être
considéré comme un parti comme les
autres sur un parti qui c'est intégré
dans le jeu républicain qui est présent
aussi à chaque élection on voit que il y
a une dynamique territoriale aussi on
l'a vu aux élections législatives puis
un autre point quand même c'est
l'arrivée d'Éric Zemmour dans le jeu
politique qui a élargi l'espace
politique pour l'extrême droite mais
dans un match où finalement Marine Le
Pen c'est positionné plutôt en défenseur
d'une extrême en défenseuse d'une
extrême droite anti-elite et populiste
alors que finalement la ligne
anti-immigration a été absorbée et
assumée par Éric Zemmour tout en étant
cet électorat revenant naturellement à
Marine Le Pen n'est pas présent mais
finalement il y a eu un élargissement
postérix Zemmour aussi de la base
électorale qui qui fait que c'est il y a
un poids critique du rassemblement
national qui est plus important vous
avez dit ils ont changé de nom ça n'est
plus un front c'est aujourd'hui un
rassemblement ils sont notabilisés ils
sont entrés en cravate à l'Assemblée
nationale donc il y a quand même tous
ces éléments-là de des diabolisation qui
payent dans on va en parler après mais
la nuque qui est plutôt eux donc ils
sont plutôt eux dans une phase de
diabolisation donc on voit que les
mouvements sont inversés si on parle
d'ailleurs de Marine Le Pen et de
Jean-Luc Mélenchon on a un palmarès du
rejet aussi dans notre code d'adhésion
et entre 2017 et 2022 Marine Le Pen a
perdu 10 points de rejet sans être des
diabolisé elle s'est peut-être adoucie
alors que Jean-Luc Mélenchon lui il a
République c'est moi gagné 10 points de
rejet donc le mouvement est vraiment
inverse pour ces deux personnalités et
c'est vrai qu'il y a un adoucissement de
l'image du rassemblement national qui
suscite plus de bienveillance que par le
passé et justement on va parler de la
nuque à Alex comment se situe l'opinion
des Français vis-à-vis de la Nupe les
chiffres sont moins bons que pour
rassemblement national 36% des Français
ont une bonne opinion de cette coalition
des gauches parmi les qualificatifs
positifs 53% estiment que la nuque
défend bien les classes populaires mais
seulement 40% pense qu'elle peut
réellement améliorer les conditions de
vie des Français en revanche les mots
négatifs fondamental consensus vis-à-vis
de la nuque 59% des personnes
interrogées estiment qu'elles va amener
le désordre dans le pays 58% pense que
c'est un mouvement d'extrême gauche qui
favorise le communautarisme et puis la
moitié le voit comme un danger pour la
démocratie on finit par le portrait
robot du sympathisant de la nuque il est
jeune c'est un habitant de
l'agglomération parisienne il a un
niveau de diplôme supérieur au bac et il
fait partie d'un foyer modeste là on
parle de la nuque est-ce que il y a des
nuances au sein de la nuque en clair
est-ce que c'est la France insoumise et
Jean-Luc Mélenchon qui affaiblissent
l'image de la nuque ce qu'on voit c'est
trop toilettes dans l'image il y a un
parfum d'extrémisme qui semble diffuse
qui est assez étonnant parce qu'il y a
quand même à l'intérieur des quatre
parties qui composent la nuque il y a le
Parti communiste Europe éc un billet
vert et le Parti socialiste qui sont des
parties de gouvernement mais c'est vrai
que il y a deux effets qui tirent vers
le bas cette image de la nuque qui est
maintenant inférieure en popularité à
celle du rassemblement national faut
quand même le souligner il y a un
premier effet c'est que finalement tout
le monde dans les adhérents à la nuque
n'est pas satisfait de cette union on a
40 % des sympathisants PS qui ont une
mauvaise opinion de la nuque donc déjà
la nuque ne fait pas le plein auprès de
sa base de soutien et le deuxième point
c'est la mauvaise image de la France
insoumise et de Jean-Luc Mélenchon ou
certains de ces lieutenants qui tirent
un peu à la baisse et qui vaporise un
peu cette image d'extrémisme qui met à
distance une gauche plus modérée donc on
va vraiment se ce mouvement un peu
critique à l'égard de la Nupe alors que
le Front national dans le même temps
voit plutôt une dynamique en sa faveur
donc c'est intéressant et ça montre
aussi que finalement quand Emmanuel
Macron renvoyait dos à dos les deux
formations au soir du premier tour était
plutôt dans le vrai au regard de
l'opinion et que le Front républicain
tel qu'il a existé n'a plus lieu d'être
pour une grande partie des Français
ce week-end il dit il faut un accord qui
va du communiste ou LR c'est-à-dire sans
le RN et sans LFI qui ne sont pas des
parties de gouvernement est-ce que
l'opinion publique adhère à cette phrase
ou pas alors on peut imaginer que non
par contre parce que ça c'est un point
très important c'est que on parle de ces
trois francs qui sont opposés mais dans
ces trois francs il y a quand même des
spécificités en termes d'attente
c'est-à-dire que dans la France qui
soutient Emmanuel Macron l'attendent
principal c'est la situation économique
nationale dans la France qui soutient
Marine Le Pen c'est la crainte que la
situation ma situation individuelle se
détériore sur le plan du pouvoir d'achat
sur le plan de la sécurité et la France
qui soutient plus fortement la nuque
c'est des attentes sur des problèmes
plus d'attentes sur les problématiques
collectives la santé l'éducation
l'environnement donc il y a quand même
besoin que toutes ces thématiques soient
confrontées à l'Assemblée nationale et
il y a aussi un point très important
c'est que Jean-Luc Mélenchon la Nupe et
Marine Le Pen et le RN sont considérés
comme mieux disons sur le pouvoir
d'achat et sur la sécurité qu'Emmanuel
Macron ça veut dire qu'ils doivent va
devoir aussi probablement intégrer des
propositions de ces forces politiques
dans son offre
rapidement sur l'anus alors moi c'est
juste pour mettre quand même un bémol à
tout ce qui vient d'être dit et sans
contester les chiffres bien évidemment
attention Jean-Luc Mélenchon est quand
même quand même fait 22 % à la
présidence attention il y a eu une
dynamique de l'Union qui est réelle il
suffit d'aller sur le terrain dans les
meetings sur les marchés pour voir qu'il
y a quand même une gauche qui existe une
gauche qui s'est rassemblée autour de la
France insoumise quel que soit les
qualificatifs que les français portent
sur la France insoumise que je ne nie
pas mais une chose est sûre c'est que la
France insoumise est Mélenchon ont
réussi à faire une union électorale et
lancer une dynamique électorale réelle
maintenant c'est vrai qu'il faut
maintenant qui autour de ce pôle radical
ce qui n'est pas évident mais
transformer cette union électorale
dynamique électorale en programme commun
ça veut dire qu'il va lui aussi devoir
s'ouvrir quand je dis lui c'est
Mélenchon et et ces lieutenant à des
compromis au sein même de cette union de
la gauche vers des éléments peut-être
plus sécuritaires pour le parti
communiste plus laïque pour le Parti
socialiste c'est le défi qui lui reste
mais attention de sous-estimons pas ce
peuple de gauche tout de même incarné
par des figures incontestables et
incontestées
[Musique]